My name is Eric Cronstrom with
the center for charter schools
at Central Michigan University.
I'm going to tell you a
story about my first project
after joining the center.
Now this project
was a challenge,
but we were able to
automate a process that
had been performed manually
for more than a decade.
On its own, the
project was successful,
but we turned it
into an opportunity
to rethink how the organization
approaches data science.
This is a story about the
technology and the techniques
we use to automate
a task that seemed
too complex for the procedural
document generation.
But more importantly,
this is a story
about how to make a difference
in an organization of how
to build trust, and
convince leadership
to try the new thing.
One of the responsibilities
we have as a charter school
authorizer is to
hold our partner
schools accountable for
the academic performance
of their students.
One of the ways we do this is
with the annual performance
report.
The annual performance
report or APR
is a document that
summarizes how well students
in each of our 58 partner
schools are doing academically.
In the spirit of
transparency, these reports
are made publicly available
on the centers website.
And they're also
distributed to school boards
and other stakeholders
as print booklets.
The organization demands
high production values
for these documents, and they
have to be absolutely correct.
And to make no bones
about it, they look good.
And these publications are
the primary responsibility
of my new job.
So try to picture yourself
at a job interview.
Across the table is
your new potential boss.
He's an impressive guy with
a PhD in psychometrics.
He's explaining how
important these reports are,
and some of what goes
into making them.
But there's a catch.
These reports that usually
take months to produce
have to go to print
in seven weeks.
Well, to quote Richard
Branson, if someone offers you
an amazing opportunity,
but you're not sure
if you can do it, say yes,
and learn how to do it later.
So how do you make an APR?
First things first, you
have to get your data.
There are a variety
of different sources,
individual test scores
from assessment vendors,
the student information from
the Michigan Department of Ed,
demographic, and comparison data
from the state and other public
entities, and so on.
Once you download everything,
you load it into the database.
Sometimes, some of it just
stays as flat files.
After sourcing all
your information,
you can start producing
the visuals with Excel.
School can have up to 23
different visualizations
depending on the
grade levels offered,
and there are nine different
Excel templates that
produce all of the
charts, and graphs,
and tables required by the APRs.
At this point, any data
that actually made it
into the database
get pulled back out,
and copied into
an Excel template.
Then you manually output
the correct visuals
for each school
validating the numbers
as you go one at a time
for 23 visuals per school
for 58 schools.
Now the last link in this
chain was Adobe and design,
where the actual
documents get produced.
There's a master
report template that
gets updated with a
fresh content every year.
And finally one last script
pulls everything together
to produce one PDF
for each school.
This is where being a
new person helps a bit.
Hiring a new team
member is an opportunity
to have a fresh set of eyes who
like the proverbial boiled frog
knows right away when they're
dropped into hot water.
Our tight deadline was
also a blessing in disguise
since we knew there
wasn't enough time
to do things the way
they had done before.
So with only six weeks
left at this point,
we sat down in a conference
room, and hashed out our plan.
This is a picture I took of the
whiteboard after that meeting.
We figured we had three
different potential
path forward, a fully automated
solution built on R, rendering
documents with R Markdown,
or a hybrid solution
where we render
the visuals with R.
But still use InDesign to
pull the documents together.
I should note that up until
this point, nobody on the team
and myself included
had used much R.
Excel was the tool of choice
for data visualization,
and most of any real analysis
was performed in SAS.
So we gave ourselves only
a short amount of time
to experiment with
R. And if we couldn't
have a proof of concept for
production ready visuals in 10
days, we would use Excel.
And if within a month, we
couldn't have an R Markdown
report that met our
publication standards,
we would use the
InDesign templates.
Like I said, I hadn't used
much R up until this point.
I was comfortable
with programming.
My background is in software
development and automation.
I had some exposure to R just
through my graduate coursework,
but the only R Markdown
reports I ever created
were academic white papers.
And looking back, I think
it was this discussion
about the risks involved,
and being open and honest
about what I knew.
And what I didn't know.
And having a backup
plan is how I
was able to convince the
team to try something new.
Now that we had a plan, and
we convinced the organization
to let us experiment, we set
out to recreate this report
from the ground up.
And the first thing
we needed to do
was prove to ourselves that we
could create a publication that
adheres to our identity
standards using R Markdown.
And there was one issue that
almost stopped us right away.
So at this point in my career,
I had been writing code
professionally for 10 years.
I've taught web
development courses.
I've taught database
design at a graduate level.
The single issue I spent the
most time on for this report
was getting a box with our
CMU maroon background color
with white text using
a custom font in LaTeX.
Maybe that just stands
out as the most difficult
technical challenge, because
almost everything else
was done with ggplot.
And ggplot is amazing.
Regardless, it's not
my proudest moment.
More seriously
though, the reason
this process had been
performed manually for so long
is that each school
is a little different.
Different schools offer
different grade levels.
Some of our schools
are K through 12,
some are just high schools,
and some are kindergarten
through third grade.
And beyond that, we evaluate
the academic performance
of our schools based
on the terms laid out
in their individual contracts.
The educational goals of many
of our schools are similar,
but some are operating
under unique circumstances.
And all of those
differences need
to be represented in the
annual performance report.
When you're manually
producing visuals in Excel,
you can tweak things on
the fly to accommodate
all those variations
trying to automate around
all that variability,
presents an interesting design
challenge.
There are two main strategies
we employ to accommodate this,
depending on the prevalence
of the variation,
and the impact that
has on the report.
You can always write flow
control logic into your R code,
so your program will
behave differently
depending on what schools report
is currently being rendered.
This is OK if it's a
unique situation that only
impacts one or two schools.
Otherwise, it can get
out of hand quickly.
What we try to do first
is to generalize an issue,
and develop a data
structure that represents
all possible variations.
And effectively, it turns
part of a school's contracts
into data.
A good example of
this is you can
have two schools that both
offer instruction at grades K
through 8.
School A's contract
stipulates they're
to be evaluated on the academic
achievement of their students
in grades 3 through 8.
School B's contract
says they are
to be evaluated based on
their students in grades 3
through 7 excluding grade 8.
Instead of a giant if
else chain in your code
to keep track of all
the contract grades,
you can develop a
data structure that
represents that information.
Going through this process,
we identified more problems,
and we were able
to fix right away.
When you have an
aggressive timeline,
you do what you have to
do to get the job done.
And to be fair, we only
gave ourselves six weeks
to learn ggplot,
Markdown, and LaTeX.
The code was never
going to be pretty,
but I'm proud of what we
managed to accomplish.
We met our deadline with
a couple of days to spare.
The new fully automated
reports that look great.
With the push of a button,
an R driver program
renders one report per school
from a single R Markdown
template.
And the best part is it's
completely reproducible.
Next year, we can push
the same button again,
and get the same reports
with updated data.
It is of course until your
communications department
updates their brand identity
standards with new fonts,
and new logos, and new
rules, such is life.
So we sent our reports
out to print on time,
but we knew we weren't done.
We used success with
R in this project
to convince the
organization to invest more
into our data infrastructure.
We just wrapped up
the implementation
of RStudio Connect server,
and we have time carved out
for research and development of
dashboards and other analytics
projects.
My next big project
is a plumber API
that will feed data to a web
app posted on our website.
And gone are the
days of juggling
flat files between projects.
Now, I access data
in my SQL server
directly using R with
dbplyr, which I'm
convinced works on black magic.
Is showing results is what
convinced the organization
to give us the time to
invest in ourselves.
And we started
adopting best practices
around data management
and software development.
Now, all of the data
that we use makes it
into our data warehouse,
and each data pipeline
has an automated integration
services package.
Because as it turns out, Excel
was our ETL tool, as well as
our database tool.
And all of the code and assets
needed to build each solution
are stored in one spot
and source control.
And we're able to spend more
time building, and doing work
that we enjoy.
Because exporting hundreds of
charts from Excel one at a time
is super boring.
And we're able to spend more
time contributing research,
and at a time when research
in education is critical.
I hope that our story
helps inspire you to take
on your next big project.
Anyone regardless of tenure
or position or job title
can be a leader, you just
need to take the first step.